بغض النظر عن الولاءات الشخصية، ما هو النهائي الذي
تعتقد أنه يقدم لنا أفضل
قصة،
أوه، إنها قصة جيدة حقًا،
اسمع، المباراة النهائية تقع في
عيد ميلاد مدرب ريال مدريد
كارلو أنجيلوتي الذي استخدمه لإدارة
ميلان، في الواقع قادهم إلى النجاح في
هذا  المنافسة كما ذكرت
في عام 2007 تتعارض مع ذلك كما كنت
تقول إن فوز بيب جوارديولا أخيرًا باللقب
سيحكي
قصته الخاصة كما سيتحقق من هذا روميلو لوكاكو
مهاجم إنتر ميلان
الذي هو على سبيل الإعارة من تشيلسي الآن
كان  تم نفيه والسخرية منه في تشيلسي باعتباره
مؤامرة مالية كبيرة كلفته مائة
مليون جنيه إسترليني، قالوا إنه لم يكن جيدًا بما
يكفي الآن وهو في الدور الرابع من
دوري أبطال أوروبا وهم في حالة
سقوط حر على الرغم من إنفاق أكثر من نصف
مليار جنيه إسترليني لكل بنس واحد.  بالنسبة لأفكاره
في الوقت الحالي، مهما حدث،
ستكون هناك مباراة نهائية
سنشاهد فيها أنا وأنت بعض الفشار ونستمتع به
في كأس أو اثنين أو عشرة من البيرة، لا
تنس ذلك أيضًا يا دارين لويس، أنت
الرجل، شكرًا لك  كما هو الحال دائمًا
للانضمام إلينا